welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one division just threw viewers
to curveball with evan peters
quick silver actor from the fox x-men
movies now playing wanda's brother
pietro
in the mcu didn't see that one come in
well a lot of us said he was reported to
be in this eight months ago but still
it's a very big deal and a potentially
game-changing x-men crossover
but folks evan peters is just the
beginning
this cast has been salivating over what
they describe as an
internet breaking cameo coming at the
end of one of mission and i don't think
this episode five evan peters walk-on
is rumbling any tummies but rather a
mere amuse-bouche for the feast to come
i have scoured the very text and the
very subtext
of these actors words to uncover clues
that have allowed me to scientifically
deduce
who this mystery cameo is gonna be oh
and by the way this shirt that i'm
wearing is our custom unusual couple
design
available for a limited time at
newrockstarsmerch.com when you buy it
you'll get the option to write in a
little custom shout out that we'll put
at the bottom of the screen of our
inside marvel after shows okay this
whole cameo speculation blew up when tv
line reported last week that elizabeth
olsen confirmed wanovision would end
with a cameo on par with luke skywalkers
in the mandalorian
but uh if you look into that article
really the interviewer framed it that
way elizabeth olson just responded with
a quick
yes and i'm really excited really it's
been the teases of paul
bettany who confirmed to lights camera
pod in late january that someone big is
coming
i think they're going to be massively
surprised by the end of the show
and they're going to look at the mcu in
a whole new light and
also have a much deeper understanding
about in what direction it's moving but
there's this thing that's been kept
completely under wraps
that is that happens and i work with
this actor that i have
always wanted to work with oh and
we have fireworks together i've always
wanted to work
uh with this guy the scenes are pretty
intense
now betany makes a sound like an oops
off-the-cuff flub
but he used these same exact words two
weeks earlier before wandavision
premiered in an interview with black
girl nerds
there's stuff that i can't talk to you
about where i get to work with an actor
it's going to be a surprise for
everybody i get to work with an actor
that i've been wanting to work with
for forever who is just
unbelievable and we we have some real uh
fireworks together again someone i've
always wanted to work with fireworks
together i submit to you that these
hints from betany are not accidental but
part of an
intentional hype campaign he and the
marvel publicity team are
laying down the gauntlet for us come on
ned smooth out this cameo
challenge accepted so as we narrow down
the possibilities let's break down this
checklist because bethany said this guy
so we have to assume
male unless he's lying but in that case
he could be lying about all of this so
while we waste our time with this let us
assume that the witness is under oath
beyond that there are
six qualities we are looking for paul
bettany suggested the cameo would come
at the end of the show bettany has
described his scenes with this character
as
quote intense using the word fireworks
multiple times
making me think that it's an antagonist
that he might come into conflict with
betany and olsen have said this cameo is
still a secret that it was never
leaked betany has also said twice this
is someone he has
always wanted to work with suggesting
that he never has before shared a set
with him in his nearly 25 years across
multiple franchises
and maybe an actor he admires they've
also hinted this is someone who will
change the way
we will see the mcu and based on olson's
affirmation a cameo on par with luke and
mando and by that we're talking
fan service baby is this gonna break the
internet will
casual viewers immediately recognize the
significance of this
so let's run this latest huge cameo evan
peters through the checklist peters has
never worked with paul bettany before
and as a potential x-men crossover to
the mcu he's certainly a potential game
changer
i could see some fireworks blowing up
between vision and a guy who greeted him
with
who's a popsicle but evan peters
appeared at the end of episode 5
not the finale his casting wasn't really
kept unwrapped it was circulated widely
last june and
despite many viewers knowing evan peters
from his work i wouldn't say he's luke
skywalker level
internet breaking so i think it is safe
to say that evan peters cameo
while quite conversation provoking is
not the cameo bet betani and olsen were
referring to
someone else is coming thank you to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for
creative and curious people explore new
skills deepen existing passions and get
lost in that creativity
skillshare offers classes that are
designed for real life
you can learn and grow with short
classes that fit any schedule
this valentine's day get creative and
learn how to make your special someone
the perfect handmade
gift with one of skillshare's online
classes they got classes and topics new
rockstars fans will enjoy like animation
film music production the class i want
to check out is narrative art
drawing imaginary characters taught by
graphic novelist ira marx
this class focuses on how to imagine and
design the kind of characters that draw
us
in and lead us on their crazy adventures
no matter what 2021 brings you
spend it creating something meaningful
with skillshare's online classes
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning there are no ads and they're
always launching new premium classes so
that you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and it is less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription
the first 1 000 people to use the link
in the description below will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
membership so that you can explore your
creativity
so what about ian mckellen magneto
this guy would be maximum fan service
and assuming one division is adapting
house of m we
should be expecting to see an alternate
reality magneto right
and wanted just pulled a magneto move by
turning sword's guns on one of their own
mckellen could totally show up in the
finale with lots of fireworks with
vision
no reports have hinted at his
involvement and it would be a huge mcu
game changer
but i'm sorry but paul bettany worked
with ian mckellen before in the da vinci
code
he played an assassin monk it was wild
but
magneto michael fassbender could totally
fit that bill
especially since he was the era of eric
lyncher who was the father to evan
peters quicksilver
but this is a hard conversation to have
but when it comes to fanservice despite
fassbender's amazing work in the later
x-men films if you were to ask a general
consumer of marvel content who
is the true magneto most of them are
probably going to say ian mckellen if
you're going broke for fanservice you
don't go andrew garfield and not toby
mcguire so i think the bigger fan
service cameo would be
patrick stewart as charles xavier he
also checks all the boxes he's an actor
whom i can imagine paul bettany always
wanting to work with i would just wonder
what
fireworks charles xavier would have with
vision and based on the big game ad
captain picard looks like he's a bit of
a poster boy for paramount plus a
rival streaming platform to disney plus
i also don't think this cameo will be
james mcavoy charles xavier another
actor who checks a lot of the boxes sure
but he played bethany's brother
in wimbledon now ryan reynolds deadpool
is confirmed to join the mcu i just
don't think his raunchy sense of humor
will fit in tonally in one division
and like hugh jackman wolverine i don't
see what fireworks these guys would have
with vision also i don't think jackman's
coming back as wolverine the dude is
done the only cut and those claws are
doing are rugs when he is dancing to
movie musicals now robert downey jr has
come up like a tony stark from an
alternate universe
definitely an internet breaker but again
no bethany worked with robert downey jr
in age of ultron in civil war in fact
most of the mcu actors can be flatly
ruled out
including tom holland spider-man and yes
james spader as
ultron they were in age of ultron
together so you can stop tweeting me
those stupid google search results
screenshots that's not news between age
of ultron civil war infinity war
pretty much everyone in the mcu is off
the table except one
major avenger benedict cumberbatch
stephen strange
how was this possible both he and
bethany appeared in adventures infinity
were right
yes except doctor strange and vision
never actually shared the screen
together doctor strange left earth
before vision joined up with the other
avengers
and vision died before strange returned
to earth and end game they were ships in
the night
and you could imagine betany looking
back on his time in the mcu thinking
how have i never shared a scene with
benedict the fireworks bettany described
could be doctor strange arriving to try
to quell this out of control sorceress
but vision
out of loyalty to wanda could battle the
sorcerer's supreme throughout westview
wanda is confirmed to return to
multiverse of madness so can we really
consider a cameo by doctor strange all
that surprising
maybe not but it would still be a very
big deal that could establish the rules
of the marvel multiverse going forward
so based on all this i think benedict
cumberbatch steven strange is our
likeliest cameo but hey the door is
still open to all of these dudes as well
as other people we've talked about
richard e grant is going to show up in
loki john krasinski who we hope is going
to be reed richards giancarlo esposito
keanu reeves tom
cruise anyone on this cruise again
who do you want this secret one division
cameo to be join this conversation on
new rockstar's official discord server
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
all your wanda vision questions to be
answered thank you for watching
[Music]
you